so thanks for having me really briefly
just so you know who I am I started a
company called Domino data lab we make a
platform as a service for data science
I'll show you one part of that today
there are other things that does before
I started that I worked at a big hedge
fund I built software there for doing
macroeconomic model development and I
got a formal educational background in
computer science so fortunately that
talked before me set up a lot of the
groundwork that I wanted to cover I can
go faster a lot of this I want to I'll
put a slightly different slant on some
of it though I mean I'm and talk about
how to deploy predictive models into
production but I'm going to talk about
it a little more specifically in the
context of a company sort of a corporate
enterprise use case and I'm going to
motivate it with two specific problems
so the first problem is how you bridge
the gap between different languages that
a company would be using so we call out
names I want you guys to tell me which
languages here would you choose if
you're going to write a predictive model
R what else Python or in Python all
right
I pretended not to hear everybody who
said Java and I should I don't even have
skal up there but I should put it up
there so what okay so now for the
software engineers in the group what
languages would you use if you're going
to write a production grade let's say
web application Scala I'm going to group
that under Java okay Java Python yeah
all right good you guys are right with
me it's perfect so so so there's a
problem here right that if you want your
production software system written in
Java to talk to your predictive model
written in our Python you're already at
you've already got sort of an impedance
mismatch and disconnect that you need to
engineer a solution to in one way or
another
okay so used to the Python fan say well
that's why python is so great just I'll
just write my application in Python my
models in Python and I don't have to
worry about that so then we come to the
second problem which is typically these
functions are organized differently
within an organizational design
structure or located differently and
what happens is data scientists build a
model and they want to get it deployed
into the production application and that
means talking to the software engineers
or going through some sort of process
and that can cause so it's not a
technical friction but it's an
organizational friction where the
software engineers say ok we you know
we're going to add your request to
deploy your new model onto our task or
into our backlog we're going to slot
that into an upcoming release that we
have it's going to be six weeks or maybe
there's a process to port the logic to a
different language or the software
engineers say you know what are our
managers telling us that's not the
priority we've got to improve
performance we've got to fix bugs so
that results effectively in models
taking longer to actually get into
production so Domino our product is a
platform that centralizes analytical
models and by virtue of being
centralized you can do a lot of nice
things with them you can run them on
scaleable hardware you can track changes
you can share and collaborate but one of
the things you can also do is expose
those models through different
interfaces and one of those is web
services so I'm going to talk kind of
specifically about that I'll do a demo
how it works but the basic idea is now
the data scientists put their models
into this box and there's a web service
that exposes those models and then the
software engineers can from one any
language they want just hit the web
service and then it all kind of works
and by virtue of having that box we can
handle a lot of important things for you
so we can handle failover we can handle
security we handle logging we can handle
upgrades to your model with zero
downtime so you deploy a new version and
as soon as it's ready it cuts over even
if there's some training tasks going on
and so you don't have to worry about any
of that sort of plumbing or
infrastructure all right let's do a demo
so get rid of all my sorry the
resolution changed messed up all my
windows ok so I'm going to do a demo in
Python this works for Python and R if I
have time I'll show switching to R but
and I should say is a as a preface that
the model I'm going to show is not a
production grade model it's a complete
toy it doesn't work well and that's my
point this is not about machine learning
this is about sort of the infrastructure
around it so the demo I've got here uses
the wine quality data set it's one of
these canonical machine learning
examples that you guys probably seen and
so the Python code here reads it in let
me just show you what that data looks
like the wine quality data set if you're
interested is a collection of chemical
properties of different red wines and
then their quality is subjectively
scored so right pH and residual sugar
and alcohol and then what people rated
them so we read that in which you
scikit-learn
to train a random forest classifier and
you'll notice what I do here aside from
printing out some like timing data
that's how long it took to train so we
fit the model print out some
cross-validation scores and then what we
do is we save we pickle out the
classifier to a file and this is all
built into two scikit-learn so this
training script trains model saves it to
disk I have a separate file called
predict and all it does when it loads is
it reads in that classifier and then
there's a little function here called
predict it takes it
yeah I can make the text ba I'll make it
bigger sure how's that did ya do you
need to check it back the other one in
the interest of time I'm going to keep
moving you can probably imagine what the
other one did so so this just loads that
pickled file and then there's a function
here called predict that just returns a
call to the classifier passing in the
the feature vector so that would be like
different you know some of these
different chemical properties fixed
acidity volatile acidity acidity etc
alright so now we want to get this
working so so great this is pure Python
code like I don't have any I haven't
imported any of my own special libraries
it's just scikit-learn and some and
files and it's kind of all the stuff
you'd normally use so now I want to
expose as a web service and for the sake
of an example we'll pretend we change
the classifier we're using from a
support vector classifier to a random
forest classifier so first thing I need
to do is I need to upload this to our
website so I've got a project here with
some files in it I'll make that a little
bigger for you guys too
we've a command line tool that we use to
sync files so this works like git
instead of doing a git push I'm going to
do a domino upload and what that's going
to do is it's going to say ok you change
the file you changed your trained up PI
file
Internet we're working and upload that
to the server one file modified alright
and so now I've got my updated file on
the server here and now now this is
where kind of the fun starts so one of
the features we have here we call API
endpoints that's what I'm going to show
this is how to publish our Python code
as a web service so the way this works
is you specify a file that has your your
prediction function function so it's
predict up PI by the way I get a one
thing I should have mentioned I've
already I've already run this so those
pickle files are saved but I could I
could run it to generate this if I
needed to so so what we need to
specify a file containing our like the
code the function that's going to be
called when we hit our web service so
that file is predict PI that's as I was
showing here this one and then we
specify a function in that file that's
going to be called so that file that
function is predict so that's my file
that's my function I hit publish and
what that's going to do is sort of
deploy my project folder including any
data files pickled model files live you
know code whatever onto a low latency
web service a web server it's going to
stand up a start a Python process source
the the file predict PI so it'll run any
initialization code in this case that'll
load the pickle file into memory and
then it's just going to hang out and
it's going to wait for incoming HTTP
requests and you know if I want to check
on how this is doing I can look at logs
alright so it looks actually like it's
ready and this should be updated now
alright so this tells me that's ready so
now what I can do just to prove to you
this works is I'm going to curl it and
we get a little sample here showing what
to what to curl so the way this works is
it expects a post request and we pass in
parameters as the post values of the
curl of the of the web of the HTTP
request so in this case my parameters
I'm just passing one parameter and it's
an array with a bunch of different
chemical properties so these parameters
will be passed in as positional
arguments to the function right so my
function had one parameter features so
that's what I pass it in one parameter
that is itself an array and I'm going to
pipe this to jason prettyprint just so
you guys can see the results faster
he's more easily so I'm in bash curl
this alright we get some metadata like
what the request ID was what commit
version of your project it was pinned it
was deployed against the file that was
called the function was called status
exceeded some timing information then
here's the the cute the key thing we
care about the result and you'll notice
it was very fast
so our dominoes overhead in this process
is about 50 milliseconds it's pretty
quick and then it's obviously the time
it takes to run your code
so that's neat if if you guys want to
see a more fleshed out example just to
show you what you can do with this
I've also wired this up to a little web
application and I should say we're also
using Scala
and my demo is going to be in Scala if
you uh well I'll go through this quickly
because it's just obviously it's just
sort of a window dressing on the core
thing you've seen but you know the idea
here is you build a little web form ask
for the parameters and what this is
going to do behind the scenes apologies
to folks who don't read Scala so here's
my predict function that's going to get
called in my web app it's going to
process the form I'm submitting this is
an error condition if the you know
inputs aren't valid this is the
important thing get prediction and what
we do here is we turn our the form data
into an array and then we call a web
service with that URL that you were
seeing earlier and like you said you saw
this in the in the curl request but so
we pass in some headers to just
authenticate so we know that to domina
knows is someone authorized to the
service and then we print out the result
we get or sorry rather we extract the
value from the results field in in the
JSON response and then we display that
back on the web form so here's what that
looks like and there we go and if we
wanted to see what wine was like with a
lot more alcohol it's uh not as good
apparently less alcohol also now it's
good so there's some sweet spot there so
any questions about that does that make
sense yeah I can do an our example but
it's it's basically the same right a
training script would save out a yeah
can you give me an example
yeah but each one like are they they're
like numbers or their strings or yeah
yeah like a lot of features yeah
so you pass dictionaries and that's a
common thing we see because a function
you would want to function to take a
hundred parameters you can pass a
dictionary just like a JSON dictionary
and we'll know how to serialize that to
the right Python dictionary type that's
uh I don't think so I think that'd be
easy for us to add if you came up
against a case where it was hard like it
was you're passing like a megabyte of
data yeah yeah yeah yeah well so you're
saying the amount of data you'd be
passing yeah well I'm saying it what
matters is the size of the data that you
transfer over the wire right so I don't
know if yeah I think that's probably the
client yeah I know we talk more offline
if there's no no that's a good question
I think it this the particular is a
little matter so anyway it works the
same way in our you know you save out a
classifier as a data file and then a
prediction script can just load that in
and then prediction function can can
just use it so I think in the interest
of time I won't show the demo of well
yeah I think I won't show the demo of
actually deploying that so let me talk
about a couple neat things that happen
sort of behind the scenes here well
actually let me talk about one so I just
added this slide during the last talk
because it sparked a number of thoughts
for me so obviously there's a lot of
overlap between I think what I'm showing
and what the prediction IO stuff is
doing I think the you know the problem
we're addressing is very similar I think
a lot of the ideas are similar sort of
separation of concerns taking a lot of
the house a lot of things for you one
observation I have and I put this
out there not as a right or wrong but
more just to highlight it I think a
difference of philosophy I think there's
a really interesting trade-off or
tension between like the flexibility
that you give to people and how much you
simplify their life with constraints so
soakin simplicity is great but sometimes
it comes to the cost of preventing you
from from having the power to do what
you need to do and on the other hand
flexibility can be great but flexibility
can gotta give you a lot of rope that
you can use to hang yourself or you know
make a mess for yourself and so you know
so what our philosophy has been in
designing what we've built is to make
the annoying things easy but to let you
do what you want otherwise so you know
you can return whatever data types you
want to return you can decompose your
functions however you want there's not a
pattern you have to fit into but we will
take care of serialization we'll take
care of deployments we'll take care of
security this sort of stuff around the
edges that isn't really core to how you
want to write your code and we're oh
yeah
yeah yeah there are a couple ways to do
that the first thing is so our are the
product Domino it can run in our cloud
two fully hosted we can also be deployed
on-premise behind your firewall if you
want to if you've got the infrastructure
you want to deal with you know hosting
it and everything you just did it there
and that's fine the other thing we can
do though if you wanted to get the best
of both worlds and use our cloud we run
your your predictive models in an
isolated docker containers that are
specific to your organization of your
project and we can set those up with VPN
credentials specific to your
organization's so you can connect back
to a gateway that's that's you know on
your site for example so that's kind of
the most common use case for our
customers so I mentioned that you know
really aiming this set at production use
cases inside of sort of the enterprise
and so a couple real-world practical
concerns that we've addressed so very
low latency like you saw upgrades happen
with zero downtime and you got it you
got a taste of this earlier but I didn't
call attention to it when you publish a
new endpoint the old one the previous
one sort of sticks around until all the
initialization for the new one has
finished and then it switches over so
you'll never you'll never drop
connections or anything like that and
you have to worry about it
similarly that also gives you high
availability will kind of detect if the
endpoint if your codes crash for any
reason and automatically spin it back up
I'll come back to reproducibility so you
saw we have we have logging we've
security in place the logs are kind of
nice you can see both the initialization
of your model and also all the calls to
it the parameters that were passed and
the result that was returned I want to
mention reproducibility because I think
it's it's particularly powerful so so
Domino will automatically track all your
changes even to large binary files like
gigabyte or hundreds of megabyte pickle
files or tens of gigabytes datasets or
things like that and each one of these
API pub releases is pinned to a specific
commit so if you needed to debug
something or there was something
behavior changed or whatever you can
always sort of get back to an old
version of everything in your project
precisely as it was when it ran
so you know if I browse back to this
thing I was doing this is what I
published yesterday or something
and you know all these all these binary
where they go do I put them in here oh
it's a little slow well you get the idea
is you can look at the are the our data
files for example so these are all my
files exactly as they were back
yesterday when I published this that's a
nice way to get reproducibility or
debugging the other thing I wanted to
touch on and you know a lot of this will
overlap with the talk before me is what
what we think are some best practices
and what we've seen work for for other
people who are doing this sort of work
ie deploying prediction predictive
models into production so the first is
to separate concerns like you heard
earlier a little more specifically what
I mean by that is two separate training
which can take along it can take a long
time and then two separate
initialization of standing up a new a
live predictive model and then the
actual prediction itself and the goal of
this is to make the prediction code path
as fast as possible so you know get the
training stuff out of the way and then
initialize a or maybe do some light
weight adjustment to the model when you
bring it up during initialization but
then keep that prediction thing really
really tight so what you saw earlier in
and what I was showing right the
training and then and then one way you
can create the separation of concerns is
to use persistent files as an interface
between these steps so we saw earlier as
here's all the training and then we just
save the model to a file the prediction
does some initialization just by loading
it back up though this could be more
complicated and then the prediction is
very very simple another critical thing
is to make your prediction functions
thread safe so this is a web service
right so we could have multiple
concurrent requests and just like any
web service will let multiple threads
come in at once so you don't want to
have your prediction functions mutating
shared state that can that can be really
confusing it's best if they're sort of
read-only and then they just return
through the through the function return
return path the the ultimate thing you
want to send back to the user
and then I kind of talked about how you
can leverage persistence your
persistence and serialization tools to
create interfaces between these steps so
some use cases we're seeing a lot of
lease or loan approvals you know
customer applies on a website for a loan
they put in some of their information a
predicted model makes a determination
about likelihood of default or
cumulative payback rate recommendation
systems obviously for music books
products cars etc insurance is a really
interesting use case both for quoting
premiums like I apply for insurance on
my car my house whatever and based on
where I live and other things I put in
it also give me an estimate but also
claims estimates like a car there's a
car crash and an insurance companies
come up with an estimate of damages in
the past they would send out a claims
adjuster but maybe they can actually
just take some information about the
crash and and come up with a realistic
estimate so that is that's pretty much
what I wanted to go through one thing I
would just I heard some folks being
earlier I was last week I was in our
meet up talking about parallelizing code
we're doing a webinar so totally
unrelated to predictive models but we're
doing a webinar on parallel programming
and are in Python on Wednesday you can
sign up on our website if you're
interested I'll show some cool stuff but
otherwise we'd love to hear any
questions or feedback or thoughts you
guys have
yeah
so what we do for cases like that if you
have particular needs when we set up a
deployment for you we can customize what
hardware you're running on in the
backend so I mean nothing is going to so
by default you're not on a GPU instance
but nothing will stop you from there
probably I think on a default server
they're like four cores or something you
could certainly use all of them but if
you need more we can run your code on on
more powerful machines oh that reminds
me let me show one other yeah it's a
single execution server but that does
remind me I want to show one other thing
about sort of the some of the workflows
around this so obviously I mentioned the
kind of the usefulness of separating
training and prediction tasks one thing
that we can do since you may often be
frequently updating rerunning your
training tasks and I mentioned training
will often need a lot more resources
than than prediction we have a way to
schedule automatic recurring jobs and on
this you can actually specify what type
of hardware you want if the training
tasks rather the predictive part is
what's going to be computationally
intensive so you can say I want to run
my training tasks every hour every night
whatever on a 32 core machine with 240
gigs of ram and you know okay every hour
and this checkbox here is kind of
magical when you when you say publish
after complete what that will do is if
your code if your script runs
successfully it will update your
published API with any new results that
were generated so this is a really
common workflow where there's a batch
nightly task that takes a new data
updates a model and then republishes it
to the API endpoint and that's it's nice
because you can use really powerful
hardware for the training stuff the
training part of your work but the the
published API is still very very minimal
and very lightweight and fast does that
make sense yeah
we don't have a first-class way to do
that you could publish two end points
and then you could have the a/b test
routing separately in your code but we
don't have a first-class mechanism for
that it's a good idea though we could
add an edge I don't know I'll put it in
the future backlog
all right thank you guys